la première pierre est posée à naître
tout juste planté voici les premiers
signes du nouveau chantier de magny les
hameaux
difficile encore de l'imaginer mais
d'ici la fin de l'année une salle de
festivités de 500 m² occupera cet espace
nous avons choisi d'avoir une salle de
festivités donc assez grande déjà 200
personnes assises ou 260 personnes
debout et puis qu'ils soient localisés
dans un espace ici le pôle anctil qui
est un lieu de loisirs avec le centre de
loisirs
ici les tennis couverts le terrain de
foot et celui aux loisirs un petit peu
excentré par rapport aux zones habitées
bénéficient de parking de manière assez
importante et du coup et en même temps
un paysage autour sur la forêt qui est
qui est assez assez magistrale et on
aura donc d'ailleurs une terrasse qui
sortira de cette salle de festivités
pour les tec un lieu de convivialité
conçu entièrement en bois une volonté
des architectes pour s'effacer dans le
paysage l'idée d'emploi du projet
c'était de faire une architecture assez
monolithique où on traite en fait les
cinq façade avec un matériau unique et
essayer d'échapper un peu à tous les
codes architecturaux qui sont le
traitement du pied de la façade est du
toit et on pensait aussi qu' avec le
recul que l'on avait su et les vues qui
ce qui était dégagée sur notre
équipement il était très important de
traiter la toiture donc pour accentuer
ce coteau monolithique on a décidé de
retourner le bardage bois en toiture et
de traiter en fait cet équipement commun
comme un objet comme une statue comme
une structure
ce projet lancé il ya deux ans est une
initiative de l'ancien maire de magny
les hameaux
jamais loin de son successeur il suit
l'évolution des réalisations je sais de
sa part c'est que
il est en parfaite harmonie donc avec
donc ce qui a été fait complètement
d'accord
est on encore quinzaine d'objectifs donc
à tenir
qui voit lui poursuivre et ça va être
ses missions tout simplement je serai là
moi donc aussi bien évidemment donc
observer 1 co 6 passes parce que j'ai
quand même donc quand même pas mal
connaissance du risque passe à manier
l'hérault évidemment la ville a profité
des fonds de concours de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pour financer
cette salle des festivités un apport de
350000 euros pour un budget total de 1,3
million